The 11th [clears throat] most common
misconception regarding Islam amongst
the non-Muslim is that why does Islam
slaughter the animals so ruthlessly? You
know you slaughter the neck and you let
the animal rther and die in pain. Why
does Islam kill the animal so
ruthlessly?
So once there was a discussion going on
between the Muslim and the sick.
The sick are people mainly living in
India. They were a turban.
And while they were having a discussion,
that sick was objecting to the Muslim
that why do you kill the animal so
RUTHLESSLY IN PAIN? ONE SHATRA,
ONE SHOT, KILL IT.
So our Muslim brother replied,
you six, you are covered. You attack
from behind the animal. We are mka, we
are masho, we attack from the front.
Anyway, this was battle of fits. This is
not the reason
the Muslim whatever he thought battle of
its that you are cowards when you give
one jka you attack from behind animal
can't see you attacking we are masho mka
we are masho we attack from the front
this was his logic though it's not
correct logic let us analyze today
that is the Islamic system of
slaughtering zabiha correct or not in
Islam
It's called as zabiha.
Zakum coming from the reboot word zaka
means to purify.
And Islam when we do zabi, when we
slaughter, there are some Islamic points
to be noted. When we slaughter an
animal, you should not slaughter in
front of another animal. It is as though
you're killing him twice. Point number
one, when you slaughter an animal, you
should not slaughter that animal in
front of another animal because when
animal sees his colleague, his friend
being slaughtered is as though you're
killing him twice. There are many rules,
regulation. I'll just mention the main.
Number two, the knife which you use for
slaughtering should be sharp so that it
is swift cut
and least pain takes place. Number
three, when you cut, you cut the throat,
the windpipe, and the vessels of the
neck without damaging the spinal cord.
When you cut the throat, the wind pipe
and the vessels of the neck, you should
not damage the spinal cord. Therefore,
cutting from behind is not permitted.
Spinal cord is damaged. The reason is
when you damage the spinal cord there is
cardiac arrest and the heart immediately
stops. When we cut the throat the
windpipe and the vessels of the neck the
heart is there pumping and the blood
flows out of the body. Within few
minutes the heart is continuously
pumping and the blood flows out of the
body. The reason in Islam we are
supposed to let the blood flow of the
out of the body is because blood is a
good media of germs,
bacteria and toxins
which contain a lot of diseases. So we
let the blood flow out so that when we
eat the meat we did not we do not have
chances of having the diseases. It's a
scientific method.
The blood flows out and even the meat of
the chicken slaughtered by the zhabya
method, it stays fresh for a longer time
because the meat, the mutton, the beef,
the chicken that is slaughtered by the
Islamic method, the blood flows out and
the meat, the mutton, the chicken
remains fresh for a longer time. All
scientific. And many people have a
misconception that when in Islam we do
sabiha when we slaughter the animal
rhithers and kicks because of pain. No,
when we slaughter and when we cut the
throat, the windpipe and the vessels of
the neck, we also cut the nerve
that goes to the brain which is
responsible of feeling of pain. So when
we se the nerve going to the brain
responsible of feeling of pain, the
animal does not feel pain. It's a human
method of cleaning.
The animal withers and kicks. Why?
Because of lack of blood in the muscle,
the muscle is contracting and relaxing
to get more blood. So when it is
contracting and relaxing, it is
withering. It is kicking.
It is not kicking because of pain. It is
trying because the blood is flowing out.
It's trying to pump. So the muscles
contract and relax. The animal kicks and
rhthers not because of pain because of
the blood flowing out of the body. So
Islamic method is the most humane
method. When we give a jutka or when we
have electrocution or the stunning
method many a time animal does not die
and dies a peace painful death
sometime painless sometime painful in
the Islamic method it is always
the best humane method of killing with
the least pain but just because we are
seeing the animal kicking and rhthing we
think it is dying of pain no it is a
peaceful death.
That's the reason the Islamic method of
killing the animal is the best for the
animal and best for others. When we do,
we say bismillah
Allahbar that in the name of Allah who's
a great we are cutting the animal,
killing the animal in the name of Allah
with his permission so that we can eat
it. It is the best and the most humane
method of slaughtering the animal.